this man has 1.2 billion subscribers
what channel does he run well he runs
our favorite channels 5 minute crafts
one two three go bright side slick slime
Sam la la life and baby zoo just to name
a few
all of these channels are owned by a
corporation called diesel publishing
which is run by our protagonist Pavel
radiv the company was only founded seven
years ago but given that they post
hundreds of videos per day across 21
languages they have essentially been
able to brute force their way to the top
but while things look good on the
surface underneath the hood things
aren't going that great in fact they're
looking pretty bad Take 5 minute crafts
for example the channel has a whopping
80 million subscribers but a lot of
their videos can't even break 100K views
it's even worse at Brightside a total of
45 million subscribers but many of their
videos can't even break 20K views
zooming out a bit Brightside used to
pull in 150 to 200 million views per
month back in their Heyday but now the
channel is down to 40 to 50 million
views per month
not a bad amount but given that they
post it three times a day and it's very
possible that this operation is now
unprofitable a similar story can be seen
with their subscriber count as well
since last October Brightside has had
multiple months where their net
subscriber gain was straight up zero
clearly things aren't looking that great
from a business perspective but there's
more to it than just that you see it's
easy to dismiss these whole publishing
as just some soulless content form
that's looking to milk social media for
views
but when you take a deeper look a much
darker agenda becomes more evident their
quirky content is actually sometimes
laced with politics and the pro-russian
versions of History one of their now
deleted videos for example claimed that
Ukraine is part of Russia way back in
2019 another claimed that Alaska was a
gift to the US from the Soviet Union
and when you consider that the company
is run by a bunch of Russian Nationals
this all starts to make sense this means
that this whole publishing may not just
be the world's largest content form but
also the world's largest propaganda
machine so here's the controversial rise
and fall of the biggest YouTube Empire
of all time
[Music]
taking a look back the story of this all
publishing indeed only dates back to
2016 but the story of the company behind
the company add me dates back to the
early 2000s to two men these men are
Pavel radiva and Merit mokomotov and me
started off as a media platform that
seeked to offer serious informational
content but over time this evolved into
being more light-hearted content focused
on entertainment as this simply appealed
to a far larger audience they basically
became the Russian BuzzFeed and would
eventually transition this style over to
their dozens of YouTube channels which
brings us into their first controversy
the timeline of this whole publishing
after being a Russian focused media
Organization for over a decade Acme
decided to launch this whole publishing
in 2016. this has prompted some to
theorize that the assault publishing was
created to influence the 2016 election
at one point even four represent the
Business Insider explored the idea but
these claims don't hold up against
further scrutiny for starters many of
these whole publishing's most popular
channels were actually created after the
election five minute crafts for example
was created a week after the election
and the bright side was created months
after the election also even for
channels that were created before the
election they simply didn't have much
time to gain momentum and influence even
if that was their goal the reality was
that this old publishing was just
putting out a bunch of corny videos like
these 35 unbelievable cooking hacks 29
things we do wrong every day and five
minute crafts compilation to be honest
these videos carried no real value
whatsoever as most of the time the hacks
didn't even make sense I mean like what
even is this the lack of functionality
didn't really hurt the channel though
they had some great titles and
thumbnails that it got people to click
and back in 2017 and 2018 that was
really all you needed also they were
posting dozens of videos every single
day so even if 99 of their videos went
nowhere as long as one percent went
super viral that was all they needed it
didn't take long for reaction channels
to start clowning on bright side and
five minute crafts but this simply gave
them even more publicity and exposure
before you knew it each of their
channels were racking up tens of
millions of subscribers Brightside was
able to reach over 30 million
subscribers within a matter of three
years and 5 minute crafts was able to
reach over 60 million subscribers within
the same time period also it wasn't just
YouTube that they were blowing up on
they also had a massive presence on
Facebook tiktok Instagram Snapchat and
even Pinterest by the end of 2019 they
were publishing 1500 videos per month
with the help of 550 employees this was
literally the epitome of a content form
but I mean who could blame them they
were making millions posting useless but
also harmless content at least for the
most part unfortunately though this
Heyday didn't last long as the company's
first tribulations were just around the
corner
the company's first major challenge came
from none other than YouTube's Infamous
algorithm as we moved into the 2020s
YouTube started an internal campaign
against clickbait for obvious reasons
YouTube was not exactly a fan of
clickbait as it simply gave the entire
platform a cheap tablet Vibe not to
mention it likely led to people spending
less time on a platform this wasn't
originally a major concern as YouTube's
user base was simply growing so much but
as the platform started to mature
maximizing revenue from current users
became a larger priority than trying to
attract new users so YouTube started
focusing on a new metric average view
duration the longer people watch their
videos the more likely it was to be seen
by more people so naturally videos that
were based around stories and the payoff
started taking off and we saw creators
lean towards longer and longer videos
this however was terrible news for these
publishing virtually all of their
content was centered around a gimmicky
hook similar to what we see on Tick Tock
today so once viewers clicked on the
video and saw the hack they came for
they clicked off
they simply didn't care about the other
20 hacks in the video this meant that
while channels like Brightside had a
great click-through rate they had awful
of your retention as such the soul would
decide to change up their content with a
new channel called actually happened
most of you have probably completely
forgotten about this channel as it has
since been deleted so let me remind you
about the cringe content they posted my
BF has 74 GFS I date only psychos BFF
broke her own leg so she can be the
center of attention now these videos are
actually from another Channel called my
story animated but actually happened to
post these same sort of stuff while this
was no doubt a cringe it was once again
effective at getting people to click
people love hearing about drama and the
gossip combine this with a storyline and
the characters and emotion and the boom
people are suddenly more invested in the
videos than their own financial future
this deadly combination of super high
click-through raids and ridiculous watch
time a lot actually happen to basically
blow up overnight but it wasn't all
sunshines and rainbows you see the
channel was so cringe that it was
successful at creating a hit Club also
overnight people love to clown on just
how fake their stories were and honestly
you can't even blame the critics I think
I remember a video where the kid didn't
want the dad to drop them off at school
because their dad was going to drop them
off in a helicopter or some crap like
that yeah it was really weird there were
also complaints that the channel was a
bad influence as it sometimes a
glorified abusive relationships and the
cheaters I mean just listen to this I
was going to marry my GF until I met my
first love I'm a cheater really quite a
video but out of nowhere the soul
decided to wipe this entire Channel
completely off the face of the planet as
they deleted literally every single
video on the channel there was never an
official explanation for this but it was
probably just because it got accompanied
too much bad price
viewers quickly moved on and forgot
about actually happened but the soul was
back to ground zero and YouTube was
about to evolve even more
[Music]
we started focusing on average view
duration creators naturally started
trying to play this system as well they
would artificially increase the length
of videos to skew the watch time they
would hide gift cards throughout the
video so that people watched it over and
over again even if the video sucked
again this is not what YouTube had in
mind when they started focusing on watch
time if YouTube really wanted to
maximize the time that people spent on
YouTube they had to focus on promoting
videos that people actually liked not
just videos that people watched longer
so YouTube implemented yet another key
metric into the algorithm which was of
course viewer satisfaction the most
blatant implementation of this is the
smiley face surveys but that's just one
of likely thousands of variables for
example they probably measure how long
we watch a video before getting
distracted and scrolling down to the
comments they probably also measure how
our viewing behavior is microscopically
different between videos and who knows
what else the bottom line though is that
what YouTube is looking for are happy
viewers which the soul doesn't really
have I mean there's virtually no one
that's actually excited to watch a video
from Bright Side at best people are
looking to burn time so I can't imagine
that the Soul's viewer satisfaction
metrics are all that great this wasn't
too big of an issue back in 2020 when
YouTube still had an emphasis on watch
time and the Soul was able to engineer
watch time but as YouTube has shifted
more and more towards pure satisfaction
the soul started seeing their viewership
drastically decline this was also around
the time that short form content started
to explode and everyone was jumping on
the bandwagon especially because of the
pandemic YouTube launched shorts
Instagram launched Rios and a tick tock
well Tick Tock was Tick Tock much of the
demographic that watched this all
shifted over to short form content which
makes sense given that it fades into the
same Tendencies instant gratification
quick tricks and tips and a bunch of
dopamine not to mention with short form
content you usually got a splash of
personality as well as opposed to some
random voice actor working for the soul
publishing machine
for obvious reasons viewers started
ditching the souls channel in the masses
leading us to where we are today
[Music]
today this whole publishing isn't
exactly doing bad as they still have
ridiculous followings 600 million on
Facebook 1.2 billion on YouTube 90
million on Tick Tock 70 million on
Instagram and 20 million on Snapchat
but with that being said the company's
Heyday is definitely behind us and their
insane follower accounts are starting to
mean less and less
the reality is that their followers are
simply no longer converting into viewers
and thanks to the YouTube algorithm this
effect will simply get worse with the
time as their newer videos get fewer
views YouTube will promote their future
videos even less which will simply make
it even harder to get views so it seems
like it's just a matter of time until
this content form or propaganda machine
or whatever becomes a blip in Internet
history and that's the story of the 1.2
billion subscriber YouTuber that's
losing it all someone else that's at
risk of losing it all is short form
platforms if you'd like to see why
companies are already giving up on short
form content check out this video but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one